anie samson luc ferrandez bon choix
bonsoir d'abord est-ce que j'ai raison
de dire que c'est quand même rare que
cinq maires se mettent ensemble pour
exiger quelque chose à nous c'est à
d'aussi tellement importants qu'ils
avaient besoin de le faire parce que
c'est quand même cinq grandes villes
cependant
demandé au gouvernement de s'occuper des
armes des armes de poing même si c'est
la responsabilité moi je pense du
gouvernement canadien parce que les
armes circulent un peu partout mais ça
réglera pas le problème qu'on vit
actuellement du far west montréal ou
dans les autres villes il faut aussi
mettre un ensemble de mesures pour
pouvoir prévoir parce que là on a body
gouvernement occupés vous en mai les
armes continuent de rentrer à les jeunes
continuent de tirer il faut travailler
aussi sur d'autres pain pour pouvoir
être et d'arrêter de bonnes choses et la
culture des médias et je voulais revenir
après effectivement parce que c'est une
chose de dire comme une pensée magique
on pense que s'il ya des lois tout les
ans vont disparaître mais l'udc sur la
démarche politique des mères qui sent
aussi que ça chauffe dans leur ville
plus ils ont besoin d'envoyer de la
chaleur ailleurs là mais c'est bien
parce que on a parlé de problèmes dames
qui ont un problème de gagne 2 rue qui
concernait quelques quartiers excentrés
de montréal et le titre qu'on lui donne
une ampleur bien différent on dit
attention c'est pas juste quelques ça
que danser aussi tout montréal ensuite
c'est toutes les grandes villes du
québec et je sais qu'à toronto et
vancouver ils ont aussi les mêmes
demandes alors là je pense pas que les
leaders vont pouvoir rester dans la
position de déni dans laquelle ils se
sont tous les deux installés je perds du
parti libéral et du parti conservateur
pour des raisons différentes et de façon
différente mais sont tous les deux au
déni par rapport aux arbitres de points
je veux faire entendre des petits
extraits d' hier quand on a parlé des
armes à feu je leur ai cité le maire
labeaume la mer et se plante on écoute
je vais maintenir les restrictions en
place orléans mais il ya ici un élément
de leadership extrêmement important où
monsieur autour a refusé de dire aux
québécois qu'est ce qu'ils voulaient
faire a refusé de dire aux canadiens ce
qu'il voulait faire il faut éradiquer ce
danger qui rend les rues de montréal qui
transforme les rues de montréal en champ
de bataille de gagne 2 rue et de crime
organisé
monsieur trudeau a promis d'avoir un
rachat obligatoire il a brisé sa
promesse faut attaquer les racines
auxquelles inégalités le manque de da
boa de logements abordables
faut séparer 102 2 catégories et les
armes de poing et le gouvernement
fédéral laisse aux villes le soin de les
légaliser les rendent les interdire
mais surtout doit audi peugeot peut-être
donné de l'argent province pour qu'il le
fasse puis les armes d'assaut il y en a
mille cinq cents modèles qui ont été
interdites par un décret est adopté par
le fédéral c'est deux choses différentes
comment vous voyez la suite des choses
au fédéral l'udc d'abord les armes
d'assaut et 1500 les armes semi
automatiques qui ont été éliminés par le
projet de loi c 21 mai sais pas si on a
des vues dans les rues des ambitions
sont utilisés parfois dans les tueries
très rare meskiti tunisie parfois de
belles de ma d'errements dans les rues
ce sont les armes de poing et sur les
armes de poing le gouvernement trudeau
dit je veux laisser les villes légiférer
d'une part je vais m'occuper des douanes
je vais on va faire des pressions on va
mieux organiser les douanes pour
s'assurer que pas de passage pour
l'instant ça n'a pas fonctionné je suis
prêt à donner un milliard pour relier
ville fasse la lutte elle même et moi je
ne mettrai pas de lois et règlements
pour renforcer cette interdiction là
c'est absurde c'est absurde on peut pas
avoir
ottawa qui permet qui interdirait les
armes kitchener qui lui permettrait
montréal qu'ils interdiraient et saint
jérôme qui a acquis les permettrait ça
n'a aucun bon sens allez faut se
demander pourquoi trudeau persiste et
signe à ne pas vouloir s'occuper des
armes de poing année vous êtes d'accord
les jambes de points ça a été les âmes
oubliées dans la lutte générale
exactement pilatus je rejoins mon
collègue luc à 100% la raison pour
laquelle j'imagine que le fédéral veut
pas trop s'en occuper parce qu'ils sont
présentement en campagne électorale et
que dans l'ouest du canada les gens
aiment les armes tandis qu'au québec
nous on est un peu à part puis on est
content alors là si légifère aujourd'hui
quelques jours avant l'élection c'est
pour ça que monsieur autour puis je
crois aussi que monsieur trudeau la même
chose il on parle de pernes un certain
électorat et ça on veut pas devenir
comme les états unis au contraire on
doit justement mettre pied à terre le
leadership c'est là que ça se voie parce
qu'actuellement il est insensé de donner
ce rouleau ou municipalité on ne peut
pas gérer comme le pl10 laval longueuil
saint saint saint lazare comment on va
faire pour l'égérie tu vas en achetant
un l'argent parce que ces permis qui
vient mourir avec ton arme c'est pas
mieux là c'est illogique et ceux qui
disent les ans vont rentrer les bandits
les gangs de rue vont les faire venir
oui mais d'envoyer le signal que cet
objet là on veut pu en voir ou à peu
près plus si ce qu'ils puissent en effet
rendait oui et puis moi je pense qu'une
des raisons d'ailleurs de quelques
intrus d'où un refuge les armes de se
mêler des armes de poing je pense pas
que c'est seulement pour père à l'ouest
je pense parce qu'il veut pas rentrer
dans cette bataille salle qui
nécessite beaucoup d'interventions de la
police sur le terrain et donc qui peut
être accusé de profilage racial parce
que ils s'attaquent aux gangs de rue
parce que une bonne partie des personnes
qui vont utiliser server et serveurs
sont en et gagne de vue il veut pas
rentrer là dedans ne veut pas toucher à
ça mais il va falloir le faire il va
falloir rentrer là-dedans voulons
trouver les moyens d' enquête les moyens
de perquisition les moyens de suivi et
les moyens d interpellation pour arrêter
ce fléau là mais le fédéral veut pas y
aller alors à la limite que le
provincial prennent l'argent mais qui
disent bon basta on va le faire on va
les interdire pour tout le québec main
dans la main avec l'ontario qu'il était
d'interdire est pour tous notariaux si
l'ontario veut bien interdire parce que
si l'ontario l'interdît pas encore si
d'autres fois pas l'interdire mais là on
retourne à la case zéro mais au moins
est hantée on est tenté cette alliance
là avec plusieurs provinces mais diable
donnez-nous l'argent on va s'en occuper
dans la bataille municipale anie samson
est ce qu'on va entendre tous les
candidats de tous les partis redire ça
en fait est que tout le monde s'entende
dans le monde est super tout le monde
s'entend là-dessus je pense que ben oui
tout le monde devrait s'entendre
là-dessus on parle de sécurité mais ce
qu'il faut aller plus loin c'est faut
aussi changer les lois j'en ai déjà
parlé et quelques temps on a beau
l'avoir les il faut changer les lois et
se donner le pouvoir est donné le
pouvoir aux policiers de faire bien leur
travail actuellement on s'exclame quand
les policiers tirent pour des raisons
pour leur travail souvent
diffusés à cette année dix fois que les
contenus les policiers qui sont servis
de leurs armes on est rendu à combien de
fusillades que nos jeunes plus de 400
aujourd'hui il ya dans les années 70 une
étude qui a été fait par par le barreau
à l'époque qui disaient pourquoi qu'est
ce qui fait le plus peur dans la loi
c'est dans les gens qui font des crimes
c'est le fait d'être pris en train de le
faire actuellement les policiers n'ont
pas tous les pouvoirs pour pouvoir faire
leur travail ce qui fait que les jeunes
peuvent le faire de façon impunément ils
peuvent tirer comme ils veulent et
qu'ils soient dire excusez moi je joue
je suis plus quel pouvoir et non pas les
pouvoirs d'aller plus loin sur
actuellement si les policiers voient en
gagne deux jeunes filles est suspecte de
six ont pas de raison d arrêter le
village comme on a changé sur les
interventions ils se sentent ils
regardent ailleurs enfin on a
d'autres villes américaines sont passés
par là par exemple à san francisco où
ils ont voulu limiter au maximum les
interventions qui peut être pénalisantes
pour deux pour une population aura saisi
et c'est vrai que c'est pénalisant et
c'est vrai que quand on a parlé de
preuves et de profilage racial sépariez
le des personnes qui ont été
interpellées une centaine de fois sur le
trottoir parce qu'ils conduisent une
voiture de luxe parce que ils ont la
lure de quelqu'un qu'on recherche alors
c'est sûr que le profilage racial c'est
un énorme enjeu mais il faut trouver le
moyen de faire de l'intervention terrain
auprès des gangs de rue sans aller dans
le profilage racial avec toulouse de
moyens d'en quête c'est très difficile
c'est
mon devoir parler c'est un enjeu
important dans cette campagne électorale
municipale qui
a débuté et en sourdine on va s'occuper
de l'autre en priorité mais on va
continuer à se parler régulièrement la
campagne municipale merci annie
messieurs merci encore c'est bientôt au
revoir